i accidentally became a meme and here's
that story hey i'm john cena wwe
superstar in the cast of the upcoming
movie vacation friends on hulu and above
all else i am an internet meme
in order to explain the origin of these
memes i first need to explain how i got
into sports entertainment this all
started for me in 1989 as chuck d would
say you wouldn't guess it for how i'm
dressed now but i dressed a little
different as a kid rap music was
becoming extremely popular the beastie
boys run dmc nwa
i was from an area of the world that
didn't care about that but i did i loved
the rebellious nature of the message i
wasn't going through any of that
struggle but i really liked its loud
brash approach the music just spoke to
me so i began to be immersed in rap and
hip-hop culture and for that in an area
of the world that wasn't so immersed i
got my ass kicked every single day and
the core of the abuse was just hey dress
like all of us
and i think at a young age instead of
folding i doubled down and went even
more ridiculous to get even more of my
ass kicked so as a way to defend myself
i asked my father for a home gym this
was at 12 or 13. my grandfather
convinced him and i got it for christmas
began working out christmas day and here
we are 32 years later and i haven't
stopped i followed wwf in the 80s as a
young kid and i did not get into sports
entertainment with any idea that i would
ever make it to the wwe i just really
wanted to do it so even doing small
shows at flea markets in los angeles and
northern california tijuana if there
were five people there in a ring i was
probably there it was a way for me to
justify my nine-to-five existence so i
could enjoy a weekend hobby the toughest
thing for anyone in entertainment is to
somehow find a way to captivate an
audience you have to create a
personality for yourself and invest in
that personality and hope people get it
and my character was a prototype half
man half machine and 100
rotten it was so bad but i was invested
in it and it was enough to catch the eye
of a scout to send me to kentucky so i
got to be an understudy of one of their
prominent performers and then i made it
to wwe
and the first thing they said was like
drop the prototype cut your hair and be
a good guy so i debuted as john cena
the most stale unentertaining character
you could imagine and was just about to
be fired after a year and a half of me
trying to connect with the audience and
on what was supposed to be one of my
last tours when we go overseas we all
travel together and in the back of the
bus people were freestyling and i
remember i just went back and joined in
and in the front of the bus the creative
department a few people were like hey
how did you remember all that like well
the concept behind freestyle rap is you
just kind of think on your feet and
they're like would you want to do that
on tv yes i do
and it really gave me a chance to invest
in costuming
mannerisms delivery personality i'm not
the most technically proficient guy i'm
not the biggest aerial performer but i
really love the make-believe aspect i
really genuinely do and the storytelling
aspect and
being the rap guy i bought in all in and
i mean like did rap battles in the
parking lots of arenas and they'd bring
in rappers for me to have freestyle
battles with and i didn't win them all
like i'd get burned i'd get scorched and
there were some that i would win and it
was fun and interactive imagine this the
one thing that i got my ass kicked for
as a teenager
dressing different and embracing hip-hop
culture was the catalyst to me
connecting with a global wwe audience we
were in production of new theme music
for the john cena rap identity so we
recorded about like 85 songs keep in
mind they're only like 16 on the you
can't see me album and i remember
hearing this one beat and it was the
beat for my time is now
the build-up to the crescendo and the
horns and the brass and the heavy hit of
the base like it had
everything and we would always use my
little brother as kind of our litmus
test because he was a really harsh
critic and if he enjoyed it i knew we
were okay and i remember him just going
like this
and like
getting lost in it and i think he was
doing what was i think the tony yayo
dance at the time where tony you would
put his hand in front of face and shake
his head and i was like dude what are
you doing and it was ridiculous he's
like i'm doing the yayo dance i'm like
okay i'll do that on tv to pay homage to
you liking the beat because i'm gonna go
with this for the song and he dared me
and on the dare i was like yo i'm
definitely doing it so instead of doing
the yayo dance i kind of did the reverse
because i figured it would be more
visible to to show my brother on tv like
hey i'm doing the thing that you dared
me to do you can't see me is kind of a
way to talk smack in hip hop culture if
like you're not on my level so i kind of
put the two and two together just really
trying to make one person in west
newbury massachusetts laugh now we come
to the internet and the internet was
like we can't see this guy i don't know
why like i became invisible and the cool
joke was to either if i was in a picture
i wasn't it'd be like okay this is just
a chair talking to you or
people would take their picture with
john cena which is simply like pointing
at nothing or if nothing was there be
like yo i can't believe
john cena crashed our party i did an
interview before this where the audio
technician pinned the mic on me and when
he's pinning the mic i mean he's like i
didn't know i'd be able to see where to
put it and i never get offended i love
hearing it i think it's extremely
creative it's something that's been in
the internet cycle for so long
but it still never gets old so as you
can see i am a veteran of memes and the
internet but fear not internet i am far
from finished my character ron and
vacation friends i have a feeling there
will be some memes
some that will make me laugh some that
might make me cry but all of which you
will enjoy so i'll be checking your hulu
account and seeing if you're watching
vacation friends because
i got my eyes
[Music]
you